the air plasma mass is actually a system
that comprise the n95 disposable mass
the mass can be used by itself it comes
in three sizes they can fit children to
adults to the elderly and the air plasma
mass actually has the unique worst first
feature of the air plus micro ventilator
which is a little fan that can be
attached onto the mass in order to make
the mass feel fresh and comfortable what
we believe was to always try to take
complexity and kind of translate into
clarity so that's how we've approached
the air plus design in the design we
we're not only looking on like the
comfort but also when you were on the
mask when you approach someone how
approachable is everything from the mass
design itself from the shape the way it
opens to where the printing on the mass
should be has been very well thought
through when we launched the air plasma
mass in the market we received actually
very good feedback from the public first
from the functional aspects of the blast
micro ventilator being comfortable and
from the design aspects we also have
feedback saying that is a very well
design our mass for winning the
president is that what we all feel of
course that we are very happy we are
very thankful because it helps us to get
some visibility for the work we do we
really overjoyed that a product such as
a mass can be recognized by the
president design award I think the
president design what makes us as
designers feel that Singapore values
design and that is really encouraging to
help us to continue to do work that
aspires to reach the standard what I
would say to emerging designers is 10
design doesn't really get easier because
you're always pushing frontiers and if
you're truly doing good work will always
be foreign you always be uncertain only
thing i would say that we've experienced
this difficulty becomes more enjoyable